my god what are the odds mark ruffalo
tried out instagrams latest filter
obsession butch Avenger are you in
shocker what are the chances then he got
his character the Hulk god
well if we want to get technical about
it and do the math it's about 1 out of
59 which just proves that this filter is
on point
mark joins a list of celebs who have had
a wild synchronicity when it comes to
this viral filter not too long ago Robin
Williams daughter Zelda Williams tried
the Disney character filter she got the
genie aka the character her late by
their iconic lee voice back in the day
rightfully so people got pretty
emotional about the whole ordeal in just
a few days her post went viral racking
up two million views another amazing
moment happened when kylie jenner tried
to which kardashian are you filter the
beauty mobile landed her baby girl
stormy webster and knowing how much
kylie loves being a mom it just made it
the sweetest thing ever
courtney cox didn't have much luck on
her first try she tested the witch
friend's character ru filter not once
not twice not even three or four times
before she finally landed Monica the
character she played for ten seasons of
the hit TV series
so maybe the filter isn't always on
point either way these filter quizzes
are the perfect viral sensation and many
celebs can't help but join in on the fun
[Music]